hey guys pete here after a two-year wait
and a legitimate heart attack scare
better call saul is back and if these
first two episodes i'm gonna be breaking
down today are any indication we're in
for an insane final season we're talking
mirrors on the ceiling a golden toilet
kim bringing out the stick when the
carrot's not working and as easy top
beard for the ages there is a lot to
talk about so i'll get right to it but i
do have to give you this warning if you
haven't watched the first two episodes
of the sixth and final season of better
call saul yet then i suggest you go do
that before you watch this video i
promise you won't be disappointed and
with that out of the way let's get into
it when i first watched this first
episode my curiosity on how they were
going to pick up with the gene scene was
through the roof and this is not a gene
scene it's a soul scene or perhaps it
would be better described as a post saw
scene and it's a teaser in the true
sense of the word in that it brings up a
lot more questions than it answers a
much repeated line about saul as a
character is that we never saw his home
life in breaking bad and here we get a
look at that to start things off the
things we can put together are that this
is after ed the disappearer helped saul
and walter white escape albuquerque if
there was any question about whether the
authorities would have jimmy on their
radar and still be looking for him in
the gene timeline this appears to
confirm that without a doubt and i think
you could get really close to saying
that kim wasn't around behind the scenes
in the breaking bad timeline based on
the way this place looks i just can't
imagine her using that golden toilet
every day and also most of what we see
them collecting as evidence looked like
it belonged to jimmy and there were a
lot of recognizable gems mixed in there
from throughout the series this brown
suit that pops up later in the first
episode which i think is the same one he
was wearing in the first scene he shared
with kim we see things like the mall
walking shoes from one of his lowest
points when he was turning the women at
sandpiper against irene one of my
favorites was this panavision baseball
cap that he was wearing when he was
trying to sell the commercials the
autographed richie blackmore guitar is
there we have beanie babies and bingo
balls the photo that mesa verde ripped
off for their logo burner phones and so
on and i really like the way that they
put this all together it has a dreamlike
quality that pairs nicely with this idea
of everything that he built up crumbling
down falling apart all of this stuff
that he collected is being seized and
taken away and then probably the most
intriguing thing there is the zafiro and
yejo stopper that we see fall out of the
truck at the very end this was kim's
trophy from their first scam as victor
with the k and gisele when they drank
for free while ken winds thought he was
securing a big payday and it makes you
wonder how jimmy came to be in
possession of it i can't linger here too
long but i'll say if you're going to
break from tradition and not start out
in omaha then this is how you do it it's
nostalgic in the right ways it kind of
transports you right back into the
middle of this world and there's so much
to think about after the fact i assume
this means that we'll spend much longer
in the gene timeline later in the season
and that's something i hoped would
happen anyways
in the current timeline we pick up right
where season 5 left off and while they
had to take some time to reestablish
where everyone was i don't think they
dialed back the pacing as much as what
we saw in earlier seasons things are
moving forward across all the different
stories and there's an urgency that
makes it feel like we are moving towards
the ending i was impressed in how
quickly they moved things along with
lalo and with jimmy and kim's plans to
go after howard without things feeling
rushed they still took time where it
made sense and i think a great example
of that is when jimmy is having second
thoughts in the restaurant kim is trying
to get the ball rolling he has
reservations and the server comes up to
interrupt and draw things out he has a
chance to pump the brakes but can't
bring himself to do it you see that lalo
has limped his way over to a neighbor's
house this is directly after the attack
on his compound and from the
conversation you get the idea that he's
helped out this couple in the past when
the husband goes to shave lalo tells him
to keep the mustache in the soul patch
and when he takes the scissors on the
table apart you realize that this is
going to be his body double because lalo
is such a charismatic character and fun
to watch i like how they have him do
something to showcase how brutal he can
be right in the beginning they did the
same thing with fred at travelwire later
when the cousins arrive at the hacienda
you see that the federales are there
they're collecting evidence there's a
shot of the lock that nacho open laying
on the ground and you notice that the
roof has a hole from fire damage which
is suspicious because we didn't see that
happen in the season 5 finale when they
go inside you put it all together that
lalo faked a fire to burn the body of
his neighbor and make it look like he
died in the attack later when gus is
looking over the evidence you realize
that he went as far as getting that
dental work for his neighbor to get this
all set up just in case the cousins lay
a santa muerta card on the body after
covering it in one of their suit jackets
and this is a nice call back to their
first appearance in the third season of
breaking bad at this point they think
he's dead which means everyone will
think the same and that all works to
lalo's advantage in the early going
gus gets a call from balsa telling him
that lalo's dead and that nacho is a rat
don eladio has put a price on his head
and they plan to bring him in alive so
they can figure out who he's working for
when mike comes in gus reveals that he's
skeptical because the mission was a
success but all the mercenaries are dead
something feels off mike is more
concerned about nacho he wants to
extract him saying he's done everything
he was asked and that he deserves his
respect it's clear though that gus has
different plans and later when mike's at
home watching kaylee he ignores nacho's
call he's on the run in a foreign
country with no one he can really trust
he's made contact with tyrus who told
him about the price on his head and he's
in the middle of salamanca territory
where everyone is looking to collect the
bounty he eventually makes it to the
motel safe house after dark and if you
remember he let the mercenaries into
lalo's hacienda at 3am so he's had a
whole day of running and hiding this has
all been set up so there's a room
waiting for him he goes inside and finds
a manila envelope with money and a
handgun and there's a cell phone there
so he talks to tyrus who tells him that
it's gonna take a couple of days to get
him out of there he just needs to stay
out of sight until it's time to be
picked up and he gives him the very
specific instructions that if anyone
comes to the door shoot in this first
episode you see kim and jimmy pick up
where they left off at the hotel it's
notable that jimmy's already awake
staring at the ceiling before kim's
alarm goes off they head back to their
apartment she has her new pro bono cases
to deal with and he has to meet with the
ada in charge of the wanda guzman case
with help from the recurring character
detective roberts they've put it
together that the address he gave and
the family that showed up at court were
fake they think he ran and they don't
want to wait until his hearing in six
weeks to start looking for him jimmy
does a pretty good job of fighting them
off right up until he slips and calls
him lalo he tries to cover up the
mistake but this will likely come back
up
he's got that on his mind later when he
meets up with kim who fills him in on
her day she's trying to save the kid who
jimmy lent his brown suit to his rich
friend is trying to blame him for a
robbery and when jimmy says it sounds
like a day from hell you see that she's
actually beaming she says it was one of
the best days of her life and then when
she thinks about it she clarifies her
professional life she really likes
helping people who would slip through
the cracks otherwise and when she asked
him how his day was he doesn't bring up
the lalo situation instead he tells her
about the car he rented and that leads
to her saying that she thinks saul
goodman would drive something with a
little more flair and that saul goodman
has an office something eye-catching a
cathedral of justice she wants to start
looking for something soon they make a
plan for that saturday and it's a little
bit surprising to think that she's
fueling this transition into the saul
goodman that we know she looks happy but
she also has an agenda after a pause she
tells him that she wants to discuss
first moves against howard and as i
mentioned before jimmy still doesn't
appear to be on board with this i think
we have to remember the timeline here
he's still absolutely feeling the
effects of his trip to the desert you
can't miss the sunburn that's still on
his face and he did go talk to mike
where he was assured that lalo was going
to be killed but he's still a little bit
in shock from everything that happened
she thinks that they can get sandpipers
settled and leave howard standing a
little bruised maybe but still standing
and she brings up the idea that they
should start with cliff maine she says
that they have to pace it right and that
if they move too fast they'll see them
coming and adds that it has to make
sense it doesn't have to hold up in
court but there has to be a reason for
everything we don't have to wait long to
find out what they're trying to do they
go to howard's country club jimmy has
signed up for a tour which gets derailed
when kevin wachtel sees him and
complains to the membership director he
makes an excuse about the club having a
two-year waiting list a clear turn from
how he was treating him just a minute
ago and so jimmy breaks into a hilarious
performative tirade about how they're
trying to keep him out because he's
jewish because of his name which of
course jimmy mcgill is not this sets
kevin off he continues to push his
buttons nearly provoking him to violence
and then he takes the opportunity to ask
to use the bathroom because the stress
is hell on his diverticulitis he gets
access to the men's locker room which
was where he was trying to go the whole
time there he clogs one of the toilets
to create a diversion he's able to find
out where howard's locker is kim sees
that they're returning and sends him a
message to abort which he ignores and
that leads to him having to get naked to
pretend he's just getting out of the
shower drying his hair when they come in
the plan was to get a bag of drugs to
fall out of howard's locker when he
opened it so that cliff would see it
howard is as surprised as he is so cliff
isn't really suspicious but it's
something that'll stick in his mind
since there isn't a good explanation for
it either kim who seemed to be
exhilarated by the entire process
especially looking through those
binoculars worries that it might be too
subtle but jimmy assures her that it was
perfect and you do see clip thinking as
howard drives off it was pretty
impressive how jimmy rose to the
occasion in the heat of things
considering everything else that's going
on and it makes you realize just how
good of a team these two make when
they're so inclined lalo is on his way
to the border where he pays a couple of
coyotes to help him cross before he gets
in the truck to leave he decides to call
hector who's pleasantly surprised since
he thought he was dead he explains what
happens calling gus a coward for sending
paramilitaries into his home he pulls
out the episode's f-bombs to say [ __ ]
bolsa [ __ ] allatio and declares i'm
going to come north i'm going to hurt
him and then i'm going to kill him
hector wants to say something so he
starts going through the alphabet and
he's asking if he has proof which he
doesn't and then he thinks about it and
says wait a minute there is proof and he
says he knows where to find it and that
he'll see hector soon he comes back to
the truck to get his money back from the
coyote since he isn't leaving they
refuse and then we get this shot where
they close the truck so that we watch
the border crossers inside as they
listen to things go bad outside for the
coyotes lalo executes them both he opens
the truck back up and tells the crossers
that they're gonna have to find a
different way north and then he gives
them their money back before he jumps in
the truck and goes back the way he came
in episode 2 mike goes over to nacho's
place he breaks the news to his
girlfriends that he won't be coming back
and gives them some cash to hit the road
for good he examines nacho's safe and
orders a replacement before breaking
into it while he's taking everything out
he discovers the fake ids he had made
and pockets the one for his father he
puts the other one in most of the cash
in the new safe that victor delivers and
adds a new envelope before locking it up
to make it look like it's exactly how
nacho left it over at the chicken farm
tyrus presents all the evidence that the
federalists have from the crime scene he
has the photo of the burnt body those
dental records do check out and gus is
being presented with evidence that's
hard to refute but he still feels like
something's up he asks about the fire
and then calls bolsa saying that he has
an idea about how they can keep the
peace later he'll go to see hector at
casa tranquila with bolsa there to
facilitate the meeting he makes a show
of it saying that they're all eladio's
men and a strike against one is a strike
against them all and we see that when
hector reaches out his hand to shake the
look on his face tells gus that lalo is
still alive so he got the information
that he wanted and he also knows that
balsa will go to nacho's house and break
into his safe and discover that envelope
when he does we see the document inside
shows bank transfers and then it has the
number for the motel safe house written
at the bottom there nacho had noticed
that there was an air conditioner
running and a little boarded up shack
across the parking lot from his room
when he sees someone move inside he
decides to push out the air conditioner
in his room so he can sneak out the back
and then come back around and surprise
the person who's watching him the guy
makes the case that he doesn't know who
hired him or even who nacho is he's
being paid by a voice on the phone and
he's just there to watch the room and
tell them if he leaves nacho would
suspect that this is gus because why
wouldn't the salamancas have already
busted into his room so he calls tyrus
to tell him that he's thinking of
running and then he hangs up on him
eventually tyrus calls the guy's phone
who's watching and that reveals that gus
is the one who hired him nacho knocks
him out and gets ready to run but at the
same time eladio's men that balsa sent
arrive at the motel he had ducked into a
truck so they walked right by to start
kicking in the doors he spotted and he
kills one of their guys and another guy
advances on his truck shooting at him
but the cousins kill him because they
need to capture nacho alive he's able to
hotwire the truck before they get to him
and after a face-off he plows his way
out of the parking lot it's a win but
things still don't look great for him
being able to get away on his own later
we find out the truck is found but he
escaped everyone in the cartel still
believes that lalo's dead and we
actually see some cracks in gus's facade
as he's receiving the news we see his
hand twitch and then he knocks over a
glass when he's pouring some water mike
tells him that if lola was coming they
would know and that he knows he can't
make a move without a reason that the
bosses can get behind he needs to find
varga alive and get him to talk this
means that even though nacho's smart
he's eventually gonna get caught and
mike wants to take four guys across the
border to find him before they do
instead of doing that gus wants him to
go get nacho's dad and bring him there
and mike flatout says no tyrus pulls out
his gun mike closes and locks the door
and says you don't understand that's not
happening this is one of those scenes
that manages to be so tense even though
i know how the story ends for each of
the characters involved mike delivers
the line from the trailer saying
whatever happens next it's not going to
go down the way you think it is and then
nacho calls his phone he gets the
go-ahead to answer it you don't hear
their conversation you just hear mike
say that it's not his call and then he
tells gus he wants to talk to him and it
cuts away before you find out what
happens at their apartment kim and jimmy
are trying to come up with something
that will get cliff to want to set a
meeting with a potential client but then
not want to pursue the case they're
trying to plant more seeds about howard
having a cocaine problem kim comes up
with an idea that she's sure jimmy will
hate he goes to a roadside trailer that
has the inflatable statue of liberty
that was above his office in breaking
bad and is featured in the bcs opening
credits sequence betsy and craig
kettleman are inside to make their first
appearance since season one she's not
happy to see him since he stole and
returned their ill-gotten pile of cash
back then and craig's reaction to jimmy
really underlines what made these
characters so much fun their despicable
criminals who delude themselves into
believing that they're the victims and
you gotta love it after all this time
betsy still thinks that saul's the bad
one when she forces him outside jimmy
lays the perfect trap he dangles a
promise of exoneration and that he's
found grounds for a large civil suit in
their case he knows how betsy feels
about him and that she won't trust him
so he says he needs some assurances that
she won't take the information to
someone like cliff maine it's the
perfect setup he knows betsy will fire
him he throws in the idea that if she
mentions where she got this information
that he'll be entitled to a cut to make
sure she doesn't say anything and it
ends with her thinking that she's just
outmaneuvered him they more or less go
straight to davis and maine we see
another returning character jimmy's old
babysitter from his time there aaron
comes in to tell cliff that they dropped
in when he asked why they think hhm
didn't provide proper counsel betsy
offers up the cocaine addiction
accusations and craig hilariously says
that he knows this because it was common
knowledge out in the yard they sound
crazy and there's a conflict of interest
but you can see that it worked perfectly
to get clip thinking about the
accusations jimmy sets a meeting and
when kim sees that he's grabbing some
cash they get into a discussion about
the carrot and the stick jimmy
acknowledges that the stick she has in
mind is huge but he knows these people
they're more carrot types especially
betsy because she doesn't agree with his
assessment kim decides to join him at
the meeting she turns out to be right
the kettlemans are upset after visiting
a bunch of real lawyers that all reigned
on their parade he tries to offer them
money to smooth things over and they're
not in the mood for the carrot instead
they insist that he needs to exonerate
craig and threaten to go to howard if he
doesn't make it happen
so true to their nature the kettleman's
new business involves stealing from
their clients kim says enough of the
carrot picks up the phone and talks to
someone she knows at the irs on speaker
she lays out their scam and betsy
eventually breaks promising they'll do
whatever she wants she leans in on
threatening them to drive home the point
and leaves feeling pretty confident
they'll never talk about what happened
jimmy lingers behind to give them the
money anyway which kim asks him about
when he goes outside and it's
interesting to see where they both are
at this phase of the plan this feels
like a glimpse of a new facet in kim's
personality and when jimmy climbs into
the car he murmurs wolves and sheep
recalling that flashback to his
childhood in the family store as they
drive away we see that someone is
following them initially i thought this
was lalo but then i watched the teaser
from the next episode and realized
that's probably not the case and the
episode ends there
this was a fantastic way to start things
setting the table can sometimes feel
more like a chore during the beginning
of any new season of a show but bringing
a teaser like what we have here can
really smooth things over what can you
even say about this house that saul
goodman lived in does that tell us he
eventually got the sandpiper settlement
could this be a gift from the cartel i
mean the way it's decorated or did he
really become the kind of person that
buys tiger striped bedding i understand
the concept of being dedicated to the
bit but this is something for a guy who
lived in the back of a nail salon and
that stopper what is that saying to us
did he inherit this after kim's demise
did she leave it for him when she split
town i still don't believe that she
lived in that house but is that what
it's trying to say at this point
everything still feels like it's on the
table in a show that always seems to
improve everything is still working it
looks great there were so many memorable
shots the performances are at a level
we've come to expect and there's an
added sense of dread hanging over all of
these meticulously planned out moves
that the characters are making i'll come
back to that complexity and how
flawlessly things are progressing in a
minute because none of this can end well
nacho's situation is incredibly dire i
can't imagine what it would feel like
knowing the cartel is looking for you
when you're deep in their territory and
you know they've got torture on their
minds there's a price on your head you
can't trust the person that put you
there and you just have to stay put
vince gilligan directed the second
episode and brought some of those
shootout chops that we gotta look at in
bagman and it's hard to imagine how
nacho gets away it's also wild to see
mike's reaction when gus tries to use
his father as an incentive it feels like
there's some real tension building
between these two characters the idea of
lalo coming north again is ominous in
that it brings kim into a dangerous
position jimmy is about to learn what
being a friend of the cartel can mean
just like mateo learned that all that
fantastic dental work came with the
price and lalo's seen enough of kim to
know that she'd be an upgrade from what
he's getting from jimmy it seems
possible that he's coming after them but
it's a lot more likely that he's going
to use them in a situation where he
shouldn't be able to move around that
easily i really love all the callbacks
the returning characters and reusing all
these objects that we can recognize you
always hear about building a world that
feels lived in and what i love about all
these things that pop back up like an
ant on a fingertip that makes you think
about jimmy's first introduction to lalo
or the h.g wells book we see in the
opening and then later on kim and
jimmy's nightstand in their room it all
makes it feel like a world where we're
comfortable where we recognize things
where we're a part of what's happening
character-wise there's a lot to parse in
what's happening between jimmy and kim
and how they're jumping into this plan
against howard the setup is there it's
put together really well it's always
impressive to watch these two work
together but jimmy committed a big
misstep when he brought up lalo's name
at the courthouse kim is driving the
action she's got her foot on the gas and
doesn't seem interested in letting up
and i feel like her pulling back in the
mesa verde situation felt like it was
the last time we were gonna see her do
something like that they've essentially
switched positions here and it's wild to
think that she's playing such a big part
in helping him transition into saul
goodman there are moments here where you
wonder if she's using jimmy to
accomplish what she has in mind rather
than working with him it's an
interesting dynamic where she could be
turning him into something she could
never be and i don't know what that will
end up saying about their relationship
mike pocketed the fake id for nacho's
father he's testing what he can get away
with saying in front of his boss and
it's rare to see gus showing signs that
the situation is getting to him with all
the darkness that surrounds the coming
ending it's a treat that the show still
manages to take time to be extremely
funny when it wants to be the way jimmy
turns things around at the country club
is probably where i laughed the most
based on the situation they created
there but the whole existence of these
kettleman characters brought it to a
similar place in the second episode
betsy's inability to see that they are
actually criminals or at least to admit
as much will always work for me and
craig is just the perfect compliment and
i mentioned how things were working out
pretty flawlessly to this point gus is
able to plant evidence that balsa finds
lalo is able to buy time by having a
body double around and jimmy and kim are
thinking ahead and don't seem like they
can miss the thing is is that howard
should suspect jimmy planted these drugs
or whatever happens to him just a couple
of days ago he confronted kim at the
courthouse telling her about all the
deranged stuff that jimmy's doing this
leads me to believe that they know
howard will figure this out and that's
all part of their plan but you also have
to expect that all these things that we
see getting set up here are going to
start falling apart so it's an exciting
place to be i'm looking forward to see
where they go next what happens when
that awful woman with the ponytail is
driving where this thing will end up and
i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about these first two
episodes what you thought about the
teaser what it says about what happened
to saul and what you're hoping to see in
the next couple of episodes please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon